[Música]
desde el siglo 19 el campo francés ha
sido víctima de un éxodo rural en los
últimos años la dinámica parece
invertirse la conciencia ecológica el
deseo de una vida más sana y sencilla
lejos del bullicio de las ciudades está
trayendo a toda una nueva generación a
esta zona remota en busca de sentido una
decisión que tomaron estas mujeres del
lugar cuando se hicieron cargo de la
tienda de comestibles del pueblo
pauline trabaja en la industria
alimentaria y anna acaba de licenciarse
en derecho
dejaron todo atrás para una aventura
llena de significado
pero que no es un largo río tranquilo no
nos dimos cuenta creo que el principio
de la diversidad de las tareas del
tiempo que iban a conllevar y demás pero
creo que sí hay que ser un poco ingenuo
al principio cuando te despiertas tres
veces por la noche porque tu hijo no ha
dormido bien y tienes que levantarte a
las seis de la mañana para empezar una
nueva jornada de 15 horas si te dices a
ti mismo porque no escogí trabajar 35
horas en una empresa pequeña donde
podría haber tenido más días de descanso
y tantas otras cosas
con el paso de los meses las dos jóvenes
descubrieron la realidad del trabajo en
realidad al principio no pensamos que
todo el negocio ágil haría tanto en
torno a la cocción para mí nunca fue una
gran pasión
pero tuvo que aprender sobre la marcha
exactamente han llamado a su negocio
todo loco que suena como todo loco en
español y hace falta una cierta dosis de
locura para lanzarse a lo desconocido
para kubica o abiertas de año y medio es
la única tienda de comestibles de este
pueblo de 1200 habitantes lo bonito es
tener de todos muchas cositas y luego es
el ambiente que hay aquí son buenos
productos y bondades son dos pequeñas
hadas
su credo ofrecer un máximo de productos
local me gusta cuando está bien
presentado y comida casera sabíamos que
queríamos darle otra alma que una
cigarrería así no es lo que soñábamos no
nos quedamos con ese sueño de la
infancia de jugar a la tienda de barrio
a pesar de todo nos sentimos
comprometidos a hacer algo diferente de
devolverle su esplendor de antaño al
pequeño negocio local en realidad no
dudamos al decirle a la gente nuestros
productores tienen páginas web queremos
que puedan seguir viviendo de su oficio
y defenderse al valores que solo
[Música]
las 2 tenderás compran sus productos a
un hortelano ecológico situado a sólo 5
km de su tienda estás contento ahora te
fue bien con los puerros mira que nos
fue bien en cualquier caso la liebre no
se las comieron si como cualquier
productor en el pasado tuve problemas
con las babosas los jabalíes esta vez
fueron las liebres así que hay pérdidas
estamos con márgenes muy limitados así
que seguro que es difícil es arriesgado
pero consiguió vender toda mi producción
en un radio de 10 15 kilómetros
sabemos de dónde viene quién recibe el
dinero que recibimos quiero decir con
eso era lo básico en realidad se
asustaba
el amor
levantarse al amanecer no contar las
horas a 500 km de distancia en tu gente
esta es también la vida cotidiana de
este agricultor
tras estudiar administración de empresas
finalmente se incorporó a la granja de
sus padres
una elección de la que no se arrepiente
tengo muchos amigos que ganan más que yo
como fui a la escuela donde podría haber
ganado mucho más
creo que hoy tengo una calidad de vida
con la que estoy contento y eso es lo
principal
desde 1959 cuatro generaciones le han
dado vida a un nombre que se ha
convertido en una marca nuevas de hago
es el nombre de mi bisabuelo y de mi
bisabuela mi bisabuela cuando empezó lo
hacía en la parte de atrás de su cocina
en su cocina trasera y luego maduraba
sus quesos en una bodega
[Música]
desde entonces la agricultura se ha
modernizado y la profesión sigue en
declive con menos del 3 por ciento de la
población francesa
sin embargo esta proporción podría
cambiar en el futuro con esta nueva
generación atraída por otros valores
lejos de los asociados a la sociedad de
consumo y la carrera por el éxito
de todos modos no podría vivir en otro
entorno donde estamos hacinados con
otras personas necesito el contacto con
la naturaleza para sentirme más o menos
de memoria
[Música]
favorecer las cadenas cortas pagar un
precio justo a los productores valorar
los productos locales comer y respirar
de forma diferente son algunas de las
vías que hay que explorar para que los
jóvenes no duden en tomar el relevo